>> CLAP, YOU JERKS.
CLAP.
HAPPY FRIDAY, EVERYONE.
JESSE WATERS IS HERE.
NO, NO, NO, DON'T CHANGE IT.
IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT, TRUST ME
SO FINALLY JUSTICE HAS ARRIVED
AFTER ALL THE RAMPANT CRIME AND
THE SMASHING GRAB SEND SUBWAY
SHOPPERS AND OUR LEADERS ARE
PROBABLY DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
LATE WEDNESDAY NIGHT A STATUE OF
THEATER ROOSEVELT, THAT THE
PRESIDENT, KENT, WAS REMOVED
AFTER STANDING IN FRONT OF THE
AMERICAN MUSEUM FOR AFTER 80
YEARS.
GO AFTER THE INANIMATE STEP,
THAT WILL MAKE LIFE BETTER.
TEDDY WAS EVIL, THE GLASSES AND
MUSTACHE.
HE PROBABLY WORE DISGUISE WHILE
HE WAS EATING A PEOPLE OF COLOR.
SO GET LOST AND TAKE YOUR RACIST
HORSE WITH YOU.
AND WHAT A HALF FROM THE COME OR
AT LEAST HIS STATUE.
SO TYPICAL OF THEM TO PICK ON
SOMETHING THAT CAN HIT BACK.
THE REMOVAL COST THE CITY
2 MILLION BUCKS.
SO WHERE ARE THEY SENDING THEM
TO?
PRIVATE SCHOOL?
WITH CNN LOOKING GET AWAY, KAT
WOULD'VE DONE IT FOR TWO SIXERS.
THE BEER, NOT THE PLAYERS.
BUT WHERE ELSE WOULD YOU LIKE
THAT MONEY TO GO?
POLICING THE SUBWAYS IN STREETS
WERE CRIME IS RAMPANT?
DID YOU NOTE THAT THE STATUE IS
ESTEEMS IS DEEMED SO OFFENSIVE
THEY COVERED UP WITH A MASSIVE
TARP, THE SAME ONE THAT BRIAN
USED IN THE STEAM ROOM.
THE MONUMENT IS NOW IN A LIBRARY
IN NORTH DAKOTA FITS OR LIKE ALL
PRESIDENTS PLAYING NEW YORK TO
FLORIDA, IT'S PROBABLY SAFER.
AND IN THE NEW YORK POST THEY'VE
THEY PUT ONE OF HIS DESCENDENTS
TO CHEER THE REMOVAL SAYING THE
STATUE IS BEING RELOCATED TO A
PLACE WHERE ITS COMPOSITION CAN
BE RE-CONTEXTUALIZED TO
FACILITATE DIFFICULT, COMPLEX,
AND INCLUSIVE DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU, YOU PRETENTIOUS [
BLEEP]
>> IF TEDDY WERE LIVE HE WOULD
CHASE YOU THROUGH CENTRAL PARK
WITH A 12 GAUGE.
YOU THINK I CARE ABOUT THESE
STATUES?
I DON'T.
NODDED THE STATUES EXCEPT FOR
THE.
AND EVEN THEN THE SECURITY AT
THE MUSEUM KEEPS A PRETTY GOOD
EYE ON ME.
THIS IS PART OF THE LARGER
PROBLEM.
AMERICANS CARE ABOUT CRIME.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT STATUES
ANYMORE ANY MORE THAN THEY CARE
ABOUT TRANS BATHROOMS OR
PRONOUNS.
BUT SOMEONE DOES.
IT IS OUR LEADERS WHO ARE UNDER
THE THUMB OF A TINY WILL MOP.
THIS AS CRIME EXPLODES IN EVERY
CITY.
WE HEAR THE TRAGEDIES EVERYDAY.
THEY DON'T GET THE OUTREACH YOU
SAW OVER AT STATUES IN THOSE
DAYS OF THAT GEORGE FLOYD WRITES
FOR THE STATUES WERE DROPPING
LIKE JEFFREY TOOBIN'S PANTS.
MANY WORK OF CONFEDERATE
SOLDIERS TOPPLED BY PROTESTERS
BUT IT DIDN'T STOP THERE AND
EVEN THE CITY LEADERS JOINED IN,
JUST AS ONE GUY PREDICTED.
>> THERE IS A PROUD TRADITION OF
AMERICA'S GREAT LEADERS, FROM
GEORGE WASHINGTON, PLEASE DON'T
TAKE THE STATUE DOWN, PLEASE.
TO TEDDY ROOSEVELT,
I-PRONOUI-PRONOU N SEE THEY WANT
TO TAKE TEDDY ROOSEVELT DOWN.
THE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHY.
THEY DON'T KNOW.
THEY'RE TRYING TO TAKE AWAY OUR
CULTURE.
HISTORY AND OUR WEAK LEADERS,
THEY DO IT OVERNIGHT.
THESE THINGS HAVE BEEN THERE FOR
150 YEARS, 100 YEARS, WEAK, WEAK
PEOPLE.
>> WE DIDN'T DESERVE HIM.
PROTESTERS TOWARD DOWN STATUES
AS WELL AS STATUES OF GOVERNORS.
THEY ON --
THEY TRASH STATUES OF THE
MISSIONARY.
THAT'S MY HIGH SCHOOL.
THAT HIGH SCHOOL IS NAMED AFTER
HIM.
AND THEY BETTER LEAK MY STATUE
ALONE.
I'M WRITING TOM BRADY ON
HORSEBACK.
>> COLUMBUS WAS REMOVED.
LIKE IT'S A GETTING SHOP RATHER
BLACK KIDS AND THEIR LIKE GET
HIM OUT OF HERE.
IF ONLY WE HAD OFFICIAL AID TO
SHED SOME LIGHT ON THESE
MISPLACED PRIORITIES.
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING.
I WILL KEEP THIS BRIEF AND TURN
IT OVER TO THE CNN CRIMES UNIT.
AFTER TWO YEARS OF EXHAUSTING
ALL OF OUR RESOURCES, WE ARE
FINALLY APPREHENDED THE MAN WHO
HAS CAUSED OUR COMMUNITY SO MUCH
PAIN AND SADNESS.
HIS REIGN OF TERROR IS OVER AND
WE CAN FINALLY FEEL SAFE AGAIN.
I WILL KEEP YOU ONE LAST LOOK
BEFORE WE PUT AWAY FOR GOOD.
WELL SO CALLED HIS ACCOMPLICE.
I BELIEVE THEY CALL THAT THE GET
AWAY.
IF YOU CALL THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS FOUR
ROBBERIES AND MURDERS, I PROMISE
YOU WE WILL RETURN YOUR PHONE
CALL.
WE JUST GOT TO WORK OUT SOME
STAMPING ISSUES.
IS CRIMES BUT OUT OF CONTROL, A
BLINK IN STATUTE IS TOPPLED.
THEN THEY DESTROYED THE CITY.
THERE'S NO CORRELATION.
ANDREW JACKSON AND MISSISSIPPI
AND RANDALL SCOTT KEY ALSO
TOPPLED, PROBABLY TO BE LACED BY
A PILE OF HUMAN FECES.
EVEN FREDERICK DOES PLAYS WASN'T
THE RACE.
LIKE BRIAN KILMEADE'S FLEES,
THAT THE HEAD SCRATCHER.
DECAPITATED IN TENNESSEE.
CHEATS --
JESUS CHRIST DECAPITATED IN
MIAMI, PROBABLY BECAUSE HE
NEEDED A NOSE JOB.
EVEN GANDHI WAS VANDALIZED IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ALL REMEMBER WHAT A HE WASN'T
YET OUR POLITICIANS THAT IS
PROGRESS, THAT THIS WOULD HELP
CITIES AND PEOPLE BUT LIKE WITH
DISNEY DID TO STAR WARS, THEY
DESTROYED SOMETHING AND REPLACE
IT WITH SOMETHING WORSE.
THE REST OF US KNEW THIS WAS AN
EXCUSE FOR MAYHEM CUP A GATEWAY
FOR MORE THAN JUST DESTROYING
STATUES.
WHAT CAME NEXT?
BUSINESSES AND POLICE PRECINCTS
DESTROYED.
AND WHEN LOOTING IS THE BETTER
THAT'S A GOOD THING, SOCIETY IS
THAT BACKWARDS AS CRISSCROSSED'S
PANTS.
IT'S A BROKEN WINDOW THEORY.
YOU CANNOT DECIDE TO GO BACK IN
A QUITE LITERALLY GOES TO HACK.
WE ARE CRIMINALS RELEASED FROM
PRISON TO COME OUR CRIME ON NEW
YORK SUBWAYS, LA BUS STATIONS,
FURNITURE STORES, THEY WILL
STUDY BECAUSE THERE IS COLD AS
THE STATUES BEING TORN DOWN.
GET EVEN OUT THE STATUES ARE
STILL A PRIORITY.
IT'S EASIER THAN DEALING WITH
REAL SUFFERING AND POLITICIANS
ARE JUST MORE TERRIFIED OF THE
MOP AND THEY WERE TO ALL OF YOU.
IF THEY WERE NUMBER SELLOUT THEY
WOULD BE ON THE SIMPSONS.
NO PEOPLE ARE DYING A PARK IS
LEADERS FELT A PIECE OF STONE
WAS MORE HARMFUL THAN A DUDE
WITH A KNIFE.
THE TRUTH IS SOMETIMES STATUE IS
THE ONLY THING BETWEEN YOU AND
THAT DUDE WITH A KNIFE.
NOW THE ONLY THEY STATUE FOR
SOMEONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
SO THEY MAKE A REAL ONE OF THEM
AND THEY WILL CARRY DOWN IN A
HEARTBEAT.
>> TONIGHT'S GAS --
GUESTS.
HE RUNS HIS FINGERS THROUGH HIS
OWN HAIR, COHOST OF THE FIVE AND
HOST OF THE BRAND-NEW JUST THESE
WALK --
JESSE WATERS PRIME TIME, JESSE
WATERS.
HE COMES UP WITH MORE PLOTS THAN
A GREAT BIGGER.
UP IN THE AIR ARTIST --
AUTHOR WALTER KERR.
THE IRONY OF HIM BEING A WRITER
FOR DUKE McPHERSON THAT NOBODY
KNOWS HIS NAME.
WRITER AND PRODUCER ROB LONG.
AND SPEAKING OF THAT, EVERYONE
AT THE BAR YELLS CHEERS.
HE FINALLY LEAVES.
BECAUSE SHE DRINKS.
JESSE.
IT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE, CRIME.
THAT THERE IS A STATUE OF YOU
PUT UP, HOW MUCH AFTER IT WENT
UP WHAT IT TAKE FOR PEOPLE TO
TEAR IT DOWN.
>> IT AND THEN IF IT WAS A NEW
STATUE.
I DON'T THINK I'M GOING TO
SURPRISE ANYBODY WHEN I SAY THAT
I AM NOT A BIG FAN OF ART.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE STATUES.
I DO WANT TO BE A STATUE ONE DAY
IN ALL SERIOUSNESS WE HAVE, OR
WHEN I SAY WE ARE ME AND MY
ASSISTANT, JOHNNY, HAS CALLED
THE MAYOR OF SCRANTON.
WHERE DID YOU GET YOUR START?
ALLENTOWN.
>> ALLENTOWN.
IT WE ARE IN ACTIVE NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE MAYOR TO ERECT A STATUE
OF YOU.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING?
>> I KNEW ABOUT THIS MONTH THE
A-MONTH AGO.
SO WE ARE NOT DECIDING WHETHER
THIS IS GOING TO BE A PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE LAND AND WE HAVE
ACTUALLY FOUND A PRICE POINT.
IS $10,000, BECAUSE IT'S GOING
TO BE TO SCALE AND IT IS
ACTUALLY SMALLER THAN YOU THINK
IF YOU ARE GOING TO BE DEPICTED
SITTING DOWN.
WE KNOW THAT YOU GET
UNCOMFORTABLE WHEN YOU STAND.
AND THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
UNVEILING CEREMONY AND
EVENTUALLY WE MAY HAVE TO TAKE
IT DOWN.
YOU WILL HAVE BROUGHT GREAT
SHAME ON ALL OF US.
>> I DIDN'T EXPECT THAT AS AN
ANSWER.
I'M VERY EXCITED OVER THIS.
I BELIEVE YOU.
>> YOU LEFT LEG TALK TO ME ABOUT
THIS MONTHS AGO.
>> THAT IS ALSO IN NEGOTIATIONS.
>> I BET I CAN GET A RICH,
LONELY OLD MAN TO PAY FOR IT.
ROB.
AGAIN, ONLY IF IT IS AND YOU ARE
SEATED.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK.
YOU HAVE TO MOVE IN SOME WAY AND
I'M THINKING LIKE GREAT MOMENTS
OF MR. LINCOLN, LIKE THE ROBOT.
>> HAVEN'T LIKED THE CHAIR TO BE
MADE OF GLASS.
>> I WILL NOT GO THAT LOW.
>> I DROOLED OVER THE HAPPINESS
OF THIS.
WALTER, IF YOU HAVE GOT SOME
DENTAL ISSUES RIGHT NOW.
>> I CRACKED UP TO THEM THE WAY
TO NEW YORK CITY.
I'VE GOT BOTH NOVOCAIN AND A
PHARMACEUTICAL THAT I CAN'T NAME
SO I DON'T GET ROBBED OUT OF THE
WAY OUT OF THE BUILDING.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE CRIMINALS.
I'M WAITING FOR YOU.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS CRIME
VERSUS STATUE.
NUMBER ONE, I AM NOT FOR THE
REMOVAL A STATUES IN GENERAL.
IF THERE WAS ONE STATUE ARE
WOULD MOVE, IT'S LIKELY TEDDY
ROOSEVELT WITH AN INDIAN AND A
BLACK DUDE HELPING HIM ON HIS
HORSE.
SO I MIGHT MAKE AN EXCEPTION FOR
THAT ONE.
NUMBER TWO, WHO JUDGES STATUES
GUILTY.
WHO HOLDS THE TRIAL.
I THINK THE CONSTITUTION SHOULD
AFFORD STATUES THE RIGHT TO A
FAIR TRIAL.
I THINK THEY SHOULD BE JUDGED BY
A JURY OF THEIR PEERS, OTHER
STATUES.
I THINK OTHER STATUES SHOULD
DECIDE IF GEORGE WASHINGTON HAS
TO GO.
I THINK THE STATUTE THAT IS
FUNKHOUSER THAT THE RIGHT TO
REMAIN SILENT, WHICH SHOULDN'T
BE HARD BECAUSE IT'S A STATUE.
WELL DONE, MY FRIEND.
>> WELL PREPARED.
NOT BAD FOR A GUY WHO IS ON I
EXCEED.
I LOVE THE BEARD.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HE WAS NOT AS COOL AS HE LUCK.
THIS TO ME IS DOUBT ABOUT
STATUES.
IT IS ABOUT HOW POLITICIANS CAN
ONLY DO ONE THING AT A TIME.
SO IS CRIME IS GOING ON OVER
HERE, EVERYBODY IS GOING AFTER
INANIMATE OBJECTS IN BALL PEOPLE
ARE GETTING KILLED.
>> FOR WHITE.
>> WRONG.
BRONZE.
ALUMINUM FOIL BALL, THAT KIND OF
SHAPE I CAN DO FOR 50 BUCKS.
PUT THE MONEY SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THAT IS A LONG-STANDING
TRADITION FOR ALL POLITICIANS.
IT IS EASY TO PULL DOWN THE
STATUE AND EVERYTHING GETS WORSE
OR EVERYTHING GETS MATTER --
BETTER BY ITSELF.
MAYBE HAVE DIFFERENT HEROES, I
DON'T KNOW.
IT'S NOT A WORK OF ART PRODUCED
GREATEST KIND OF A COMMEMORATION
SO WE SHOULD JUST DECIDE WHO OUR
NEW HEROES ARE.
THE GUY WHO PUT THE CHEESE AND
THE CROSS.
>> BUT WHY SHUT THE HORSE AT THE
SUPPER.
>> THE HORSE DID NOTHING WRONG.
THE FIRST DID NOTHING WRONG.
WHO ARE OUR MODERN HEROES RIGHT
NOW.
REAL HOUSEWIVES?
I THINK, KAT, YOU MIGHT HAVE
SOME KIND OF IDEA WHAT MATTERS
MOST OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE, GIVEN
THAT YOU ARE UNDER 40, JUST
ABOUT.
>> I'M SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER 40.
THAT'S OKAY BECAUSE I'M SO WIFE
AND ACCOMPLISHED.
I'M VERY ACCOMPLISHED AND SMART
SO PEOPLE FORGET THERE'S NO WAY
THAT SHE COULD BE THAT YOUNG.
SO I GET IT.
I GET THAT ALL THE TIME.
REALLY, SHE SO SUCCESSFUL.
HOW IS SHE NOT 50.
>> MY ADVICE, DON'T GROW A BEARD
.
>> I CAN'T.
WHENEVER THIS HAPPEN NOW IS FIND
OUT THINGS HAPPEN.
I DON'T NOTICE THE STATUES.
>> I WAS ON MY PHONE THE WHOLE
TIME.
>> ME TO.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW SOMETHING.
>> OH, WOW, I DIDN'T EVEN NOTE
THAT WAS BARREN WHAT THAT WAS.
I'M SURE AT BEEN AROUND THAT
COME ALL THE STATUES, BUT I ALSO
WANTED TO CLEAR THAT YOU ARE NOT
JOKING.
WHEN YOU HOSTED FOR GREAT FOR
YOUR BIRTHDAY, AND YOU HAD SOME
QUESTIONS FOR ME ABOUT HOSTING
THE SHOW WHEN YOU ARE VERY MUCH
LIKE WHILE I HAVE YOU HERE --
>> AND THEN YOU TRIED TO LEAVE.
>> IT STILL IN MOTION.
>> THERE'S BEEN SOME SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUES AND WE ARE WORKING
ON THOSE.
>> I THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE
THAT SUPPORTIVE OF ME.
>> THAT'S WHY WE ARE NEGOTIATING
AND PRIVATE AS OPPOSED TO THE
PUBLIC.
>> FIRST YOU HAVE TO BUY THE
LAND.
>> WE SAW NOTHING.